work rise and grind no day's off oh no
everyone in my small gathering we always
left oh i had three almonds last night
what happened uh-oh oops i bought a
baseball team
oh city inspector what's that you're
coming in one hour we need to clean up
or we can't play
quick summer distraction i'm local
miracle alex smith focus on me
what if we delay no we're sticking to
schedule damn change your name the
sponsors care now
uh we're the washington football
team wait hurry make a mascot jamal
change into something presentable and
what about player safety grinnell
heights has an active volcano
fine for volcano safety will ban jersey
swamps oh
get up or stay down i respect you now
hey
hey why don't we go turn grog back on
blaze had time on gronk
i'm here to see if the town is decoded
everything is fine
here interesting introducing our new
mascot
we're tv the team monster
you're good to play football
[Music]
if you thought this video was a home run
hit the subscribe button
what you don't want to strike out on
future episodes oh kyler this is a
football thing
i'll see you at the world series can he
not hear me down there
all right thanks for letting me stand on
this chair